Allt från tidigt Magento-stadiet när allting var open source och nu blir vi väldigt nördiga.
Ja, vi har Magento.
Ni har Magento idag.
Det är vi och två till i Sverige.
Det finns två till.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om det själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har reda en dessbra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Då välkomnar vi Fedja Porovic till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Tack Joel, kul att vara här.
Ja, och för en gångs skull så ska vi inte tilltala de här riktiga konverteringsnördarna och bara prata Facebook och Google Ads och hur man ska skruva 2% upp och ner, utan idag ska vi prata lite grann mer om dina tankar kring investeringar, bolagsbyggande och många mer lite större frågor, och lite mer om dig som person.
Det blir kul.
Jag vill också ge dig lite cred för att vanligtvis är folk väldigt noga med att få ut alla frågor i förväg, men du var nästan tvärtom ganska noga med att vi bara kör och så får jag svara naturligt i stället.
Det brukar bli bättre så.
Tack för det.
Jag har också märkt när jag spelar in saker två gånger att den andra rekordningen alltid blir sämre.
Och får jag frågor eller förberedelse så känns det som att då har mitt huvud svarat på det redan utförligt.
Så att den andra gången när jag väl blir intervjuad så blir det väldigt kortfattat.
Så därför kör vi spontant och helt off.
Så vi får se, vi kanske säger något riktigt opassande men det är bara bra för att det är ändå en relativt...
Tidigare har jag ju bara riktat mig mot hälsovärlden men nu är det lite mer allmänt.
Så jag behöver ju några sådana här scoop, några riktigt horribla meningar som du säger om resten av Företag Sverige.
Så om du kan bjuda på en eller två sådana så...
Ja, väldigt tacksam.
Verkligen, du får gräva.
Ja, jag ska satsa på det.
Om man nu inte...
Vad ska man säga?
Om man nu lyssnar på denna podden och aldrig har läst ehandel.se, Break It eller lyssnat på en annan podd, då man inte vet vem Fedja på Robich är.
Vem är Fedja på Robich då?
Jag är CD-entreprenör och jag har jobbat med ehandel primärt i femton år.
Och ehandelfyr som inte förstår dig är det som du också Joel jobbar med och det är att sälja saker på nätet i alla dess konst och former.
Allt från tidigt Magento-stadiet när allting var open source och nu blir vi väldigt nördiga.
Ja, vi har Magento.
Ni har Magento idag.
Det finns ju fortfarande såklart.
Det är vi och två till i Sverige.
Det finns två till.
Det är några till som har Magento.
Ända sedan den tiden fram till Shopify-tiden idag så har jag jobbat mycket med ehandel.
Däremellan hade jag startat en mobilapplikation slutet 2009-2010 som egentligen handlade om att ta människor från A till B med hjälp av taxi som var typ Uber i lång tid innan Uber existerade eller kom till Sverige i alla fall.
Det var väl tankenium i min frustration efter studierna och när jag började jobba som konsult.
Så jag har startat lite olika bolag, investerat i lite olika bolag.
Och sålt ett par olika bolag nu.
Jag tänker att vi ska komma tillbaka till det lite grann för det är rätt spännande.
Under min research här om dig, det var ju fruktansvärt att göra research om dig för det finns ganska många avsnitt att lyssna igenom och ganska många poddar och jag tycker om att verkligen gräva i folk.
Men då såg jag att den här taxijakt eller taxismart gick i konkurs här för en halv vecka sedan.
Har du suttit och väntat?
Det är inte mitt längre så nu ska det gå under.
Är det så?
Nej verkligen inte.
Jag har ju hoppas, efter att vi sålde det 2012 så tog Mohamed över som drev en av Stockholms största taxinattverk.
Han hade många taxichaufförer anslutna och som jobbade direkt för honom.
Han var ganska perfekt fit.
Han var helt perfekt fit.
Han i sin tur hittade två entreprenörer från Luleå som hade startat online-pizza.
Okej, all around.
Och egentligen fyra entreprenörer som slog samman.
Det var två från Luleå och sedan två till som hade startat online-pizza.
Och det var de två mer okända som han sålde sen, eller som han gick ihop med där Taxi Smart och Lilla Taxiakt var ganska stort ändå.
Så fick in över 500-tusen chaufförer i sin pick.
Så jag har hejat på från sidlinjen, men tyvärr som du ser det gick i gravid nu för två och en halv vecka sedan.
Ja, det är spännande.
Det känns som att alltid när det kommer en ny trend, eller jag vet inte vad jag ska kalla det, trend, men en ny applikation före någonting, eller en ny affärsidé inom någonting.
Det kommer ju liksom 200 stycken, och det är typ en eller två som ska överleva.
Och det måste vara samma i er branscher också.
Nej men det var en spännande tid för att jag var ju precis i studierna, jag hade, det gick klart universitetet, jag pluggade lite på handels, och sen så drev vi den taxi smart applikationen, lanserade den, fick in flera hundra chaufförer, jag kände att det gick bra.
Så jag kände att jag hade all möjlighet i världen att ta in kapital, men man var ung och dum, och sprang säkert hundratals möten, och för tretton år sen så var det ett helt annat företagsklimat, det var mycket svårare att ta in kapital än det är idag, och det var definitivt mycket svårare som väldigt ung, oerfaren, första gångsentrepnör att ta in kapital.
Så att det slutade med att jag försökte pitcha Taxi Stockholm, för att de skulle bygga den här applikationen och att jag skulle kunna bygga den åt dem.
Ni kan få en liknande men de trodde inte på att applikation mobilapp var framtiden.
Nej det gick ju bra.
Nej.
Ja är det skit.
Kan vi få, vi ska inte fastna i taxi.
Taxi i alla fall det är lätt att göra.
Men kan vi få en liten, för just nu är du ju mest känd för på Råbets Group.
Eller i alla fall på något sätt paraplyt för alla andra grejer du är känd för kanske.
Men vad är på Råbets Group egentligen?
Är det liksom en, är det ett investeringsbolag eller är det en marknadsföringsgrej eller är det en grow?
Nej men på Råbets Group för att förstå varför vi startade det så måste man gå tillbaka till att jag har gjort lite olika saker i livet.
Vi har varit på olika konsultbyråer och jag har jobbat med väldigt många konsultbyråer och känt en frustration i att det alltid finns två sidor någonstans där man har en brandsida på ena sidan och en konsultbyrå på andra sidan.
Och de har oftast olika mål och byrån vill en sak, vilket är att öka sina billables, skicka högre fakturer.
Företagssidan, det vill säga varumärkesidan, vill en helt annan sak, man vill sänka sina kostnader, man vill ha så låga konsultarvoden som möjligt.
Är det så här cyniskt i verkligheten?
Jag tycker det ja.
Och det är två helt olika sidor och det känns som att man aldrig arbetar åt samma håll och mot samma mål, vilket är få fler nöjda kunder i slutet av dagen.
För allting handlar om att kunderna, slutkonsumenten, ska vara nöjd.
Alltså folk struntar i grund och botten om det heter gymkompagniet eller om det heter parobitsgrupp.
De handlar ju om sin utrustning och vill att den utrustningen ska fungera så många år som möjligt.
Och det jag gjorde då när jag startade parobitsgrupp var att jag vill göra en annorlunda konsultviro.
Och jag har hört den här storyn från andra konsultviroer också, att alla som startar en viro säger att nej men vi ska göra ett avstamp, vi ska göra någonting helt annorlunda.
Något helt galet.
I mitt fall så visar det sig ändå vara sant i och med att vi bytte affärsmodell helt.
Vi har en...
Kan du inte förklara affärsmodellen?
Absolut, så en traditionell konsultbyros affärsmodell handlar om att man skickar fakturer baserat på tid.
Det vill säga, jag har gjort 23 timmar.
Jag skickar 23 000, oftast 1000-1200 i timmen.
Är man väldigt duktig så skickar man dyrare fakturer.
En marknadsföringsbyro kan ha twekat det lite och sagt att okej men vi har en procent på hur mycket du spenderar.
För vi vet att desto mer du spenderar desto mer jobb är det oftast.
Problemet med den här tesen är att de senaste åren så har AI gjort att det är enklare att skala än vad det historiskt var.
För när du skalar visserligen kan du få fler länder och det blir större komplexitet.
Men det är väldigt mycket lättare att gå från att spendera 1 miljon till 10 miljoner idag.
Jämfört med vad det var för bara några år sedan.
Så att vår konsultbyrå tar egentligen en procent på net sales-försäljningen.
Efter returer, efter moms och oftast mot en GP3, alltså hur mycket profit finns det.
Så det finns ett incitament att bolaget i grunden är lönsamt.
Och så tar man en procent, en cut på det.
Men bygger det på att ni alltid måste hantera hela marknadsföringen?
Det bygger absolut på att vi måste ha större insyn, dels större insyn och dels hanterar vi allt för ofta en stor del av vad vi kallar för tillväxtflödet.
Det vill säga kundanskaffning, konvertering, återaktivering, lojalitetsplanering så att folk, eller så att man har större del av affären.
Och då kräver det också att vi, ja men vi har mycket färre kunder, eller partner som vi kallar våra kunder.
Och när vi är så sammansvetsade så händer det att vi ser ett synergier i att vi kanske ska äga bolaget tillsammans.
Och då går vi in som investeringskapacitet, vi kanske går in med kapital, vi kanske går in med resurser, vi kanske subventionerar våra tjänster och ändrar affärsmodell så att det är ett helt annat upplägg.
Och det här går ju såklart från case to case och det ser olika ut.
Men i grund och botten handlar det om att vi vill ha en större affär med färre kunder för att jobba mer kvalitativt så att en person i princip kan jobba med ett bolag, även om den är konsult hos oss.
Hur gör ni när det är lite större bolag och de redan har andra byråer de jobbar med eller de har folk in-house att jobba med och de kanske inte vill släppa upp allting till er för att de har redan ett inkörtsystem.
Hur tar ni reda på er katt då så att säga?
Det är inte jättesvårt egentligen, utan man behöver fortfarande räkna på det.
Dels måste vi lita på att de andra gör sitt jobb, för att vi blir ju beroende.
GP3-profiten är ju beroende på att produkt ska köpa in produkter, det ska finnas lager, det ska skickas ut saker från lager, kundkänns får inte tabba sig.
Det här är de enkla sakerna.
Finns det dels andra byråer med så måste vi titta på och se de här byråernas arbete vettigt ut.
Känns det som att vi kan ställa oss bakom det här?
Och gör det inte det så gör vi inte det.
Då tar vi inte oss andra uppdraget.
Så vi tackar United, jag skulle säga 99% av alla uppdragsförfrågningar vi får.
Är det er största USP skulle du säga?
Det är ju en affärsmodell på något sätt, men tänkte du någonting annat när du startade att du skulle jobba på något annat sätt än just affärsmodellen?
Vi tänkte ju att vi aldrig kommer, vi kan ju inte bli ett enormt konsultbolag, även om vi får in så många förfrågningar.
Ni har ändå vuxit väldigt fort.
Vi har vuxit väldigt fort, men vi kommer inte vara 5-600 anställda som vi teoretiskt sett skulle kunna vara.
Om vi hade tagit in och tackat ja till allt och alla, till höger och vänster, vi har ett enormt inbarnflöde som du nämnde, jag är med i många poddar, vi syns mycket, vi hörs mycket, och vi är en av de få bolagen som har revererat riktiga resultat.
Så att vi skulle kunna ha vuxit väldigt mycket snabbare.
Istället har vi capat någonstans att vi kommer inte vara mer än 25 till max kanske 35-40 anställda.
Hur länge tror du att du håller den?
Nej men vi kommer inte vara det Joel, jag vet hur du tänker och någonstans värderar jag också tid med familj, tid med barn som är små.
När du har vuxit över 12 personer och ser att det är väldigt mycket administration, hur man är en vridd och vän, det har mellan chefer, har ansvariga, operations, management, så hamnar alltid skiten i slutändan på dig.
Så att du kommer få saker som brinner till högre vänster.
Jag gillar att vara operativ, arbeta med konton, sitta med partners, göra strategisessioner, rådda i konton själv.
Och ska jag kunna göra det så kan vi inte växa till ett alldeles för stort bolag.
Och någonstans har jag lärt mig att konsultbiroer värderas på ett sätt, varumärken värderas på ett annat sätt.
Så vi kommer fortsätta att samarbeta och köpa andelar, ganska stora andelar i varumärken, eller multi brand stores, just nu har det varit mer varumärken, som drivs med ett specifikt syfte som är att vi vill göra bra för människan, vi vill göra bra för planeten.
Så mer ett syftesdrivet varumärke som vill växa snabbt och sen bli andelsägare i det varumärket, istället för att bygga en enorm byrå.
Vi gör ingen vinst i våran byrå de senaste två åren, det har aldrig varit planen att göra någon vinst heller.
Okej, men är det så att du ser då byrån som nästan ett sätt att scouta bolag?
Är det din långsiktiga plan?
Det är det.
Så byrån är absolut, det har jag inte sagt någon annanstans.
Byrån är ett sätt för mig och för teamet att scouta vilken potential vi har i e-handelssverige, bli delägare i bolag där man ser synergier att jag och byrån bidrar med X, varumärket och personerna bakom, founders bidrar med Y.
Då ska helst X plus Y bli väldigt mycket mer än 1 plus 1 lika med 2.
Utan mer som en exponentiell kurva.
En icke riktig fråga då och en riktig fråga, men om man har jobbat med dig i tre år som bolag och du inte har sagt att du vill investera i det bolaget, är man då fucked for life?
Det har man inte hämtat.
Det går ganska fort innan jag kommer med den propån.
Så har vi samarbetat tillsammans i tre år, vilket jag har gjort med några brands då.
Så man är inte fucked for life, men man har gjort ett ställningstagande att vi kanske inte ska vara delägare ihop.
Dels så tror jag att kanske potentialen till, eller hävstången är för liten.
Det kan vara att bolaget i den är för stort.
Skulle jag och du Joel börja jobba ihop, så ser vi ju ändå någonstans att det finns en grundläggande värdering i gymkompaniiet.
Den på ner att den skulle vara 100 miljoner.
Jag vill helst ha ett stake som är nära 50 procent.
Skulle du då släppa 50 procent, skulle jag behöva betala 50 miljoner.
Isch, säg en gång i revenue, i och med att lönsamheten inte är jätte jätte hög.
Om vi skulle säga 1 till 1,5 gånger revenue, så måste jag betala någonstans 50 till 75 miljoner.
De 50 till 75 miljonerna kan jag använda mig av i ett annat varumärke, ett annat skede.
Och få det varumärke kanske att accelerera snabbare och ha en större hävstång i slutet.
Jag jobbar mycket mot tillväxtdrivna lönsamhetsbolag, där vi också kan få utdelning längs vägen.
Och jag vill bara säga så att, skulle man investera i ett bolag som är tillräckligt stort, som har nått någon viss av framgång redan, så är mitt bidrag ganska begränsat.
Det betyder inte att det är helt uterslutet att jag nån gång i framtiden gör den typen av investeringar.
Men just nu så har jag fokuserat på mindre bolag som har antingen tufft, en nedåtgående trend som man vill vända, eller inte har fått fart på sin affär men sitter på fantastiska produkter.
Eller är det en innovation eller en bra idé?
Nej men jag köper det.
Men finns det inte en nackdel i att, jag bara gissar, men den sortens företag som du nämner, om man lyssnar på din andra podd så känner man till Västerbåtens Sopa har du ju snackat en del om, och Mokkberg har du ju pratat en del om, och André och Skin, det kanske är dina tre kändaste här idag.
Men det är ju ändå entreprenörer som är väldigt tidigt i sin fas, och även ifall man kanske har mycket mer erfarenhet bak i livet och sånt där, så är det ju en jäkla skillnad på vad man gör när man omsätter en miljon och hur man funkar som 10 miljoner och 50 miljoner och 100 miljoner.
Alltså sättet man måste ställa in, mindsetet och hur man jobbar.
Är du inte rädd att du mest sitter i liksom samtal med entreprenörer om hur de ska utvecklas som personer?
Drivs det av det jobbet eller är det lite jobbigt?
Nej det är inte jobbigt, jag drivs såklart av ledarskap och utveckling.
Jag har ju själv jobbat på det i de senaste decenniet.
Och jag skulle säga att det här är den roligaste delen i entreprenörskapen.
Det är i början när allting är okänt, potentialen är enorm.
Ideerna bara sprutar ut.
När man sen, som de tre bolagen du nämner, har omsatt eller omsätter 50 miljoner plus, så blir det en annan typ av frågeställning, det blir produktionssvårigheter man hinner producera, det blir tillväxtsvårigheter, man har anställt människor, så det blir andra typer av problem.
Jag ser inte att de problemen är mindre eller sämre, eller tråkigare att arbeta med, men det skiktlar inte lika mycket.
De här fjärran och magnen är lite borta.
Jag fattar.
Sen tycker jag också att utmaningarna är mycket större i början.
Där måste du verkligen knäcka koden till hur vi ska få till det här bolaget att fungera.
Det är mycket svårare att bygga ett varumärke som har låg volym i dag jämfört med vad det är om jag skulle kliva in i ett bolag som säljer redan för 10 miljoner i månaden.
Där ser det mer ut som en optimeringsutmaning där man kan optimera och skruva på befintligt jämfört med att man måste skapa och komma på allting från scratch.
Jag är lite fascinerad.
Du nämnde det här att du har jobbat med ledarskap sådant i tio år på dig själv.
På vilket sätt då?
Dels har jag läst böcker, jag har gått hos en företagscout.
Jag jobbar mycket tillsammans med våra anställda och partners och åker bort tillsammans.
Nu har vi en kickoff till exempel i september för Probeitch Group, ibland åker jag iväg med våra partners.
Jag försöker göra typer av getaways där man lär känna varandra på djupet.
Man sitter mycket längre, mycket längre tid, spenderar tid.
Allt handlar i grund och botten om bra kommunikation.
Har man bra kommunikation och kör med en väldigt öppna kort, vilket alla runt mig vet att jag gör, ju mer att jag har inte tid att spela.
Så det rakare öppna kort man, men väldigt osvenskt av sig, så tycker jag att man utvecklas mer som person, man utvecklas mer i teamet, man utvecklas mer i den gruppen man tillhör.
Jag skämtade lite här när vi satt upp stolarna lite, att jag, när jag testat satt in stol, märklig grej att säga i en podd, men när jag testat in stol så försökte jag härma den pose du skulle ha som en expert har.
Du har ju lite sådana här expertstatus, och jag tänker att det finns en viss fara i att ha det, eftersom folk kommer komma till dig med frågor, och du förväntar svara och då kommer du antagligen svara.
Och då kan man lätt bli lite kär i sina egna tankar, eller man fastnar liksom i sitt tankesätt, för att det är det man blir duktig på, och så förkovrar man sig det.
Hur gör du för att inte bli liksom fast in your ways, utan hålla ödmjukhet och faktiskt inte omge dig med ja-sägare, om du förstår vad jag menar.
Nej men det är ju svårt såklart.
Dels som du nämner så har jag någon form av expert-status i branschen.
Jag känner att jag kan en hel del, men det finns ju alltid mer att lära.
Jag spender minst 10-20 timmar i veckan på att utbilda mig själv.
Dels scrollar jag TikTok och mitt TikTok-flöde är fyllt av e-handelsentreprenörer.
Jag tänkte säga, får jag också säga att jag utbildar mig själv när jag scrollar Facebook?
Det är bra eller hur?
TikTok är underskattat som läromedel.
Jag tror att jag lär mig mer ifrån TikTok idag än vad jag någonsin har gjort ifrån böcker eller ifrån bloggar eller coacher eller någonting annat.
Det är där jag utvecklas snabbast och mest.
En stor del av idéerna man får, får man ju såklart av andra runt om i världen.
Mitt TikTok-flöde är i alla fall väldigt bra.
Men handlar det om, för det jag är utelikt efter här är, jag bara gissar att när du säger att du utbildas via TikTok så är det liksom rent konkreta åtgärder man kan göra för att optimera flöden och sånt där.
Men, såsom du utvecklas eller den här gruppen på Robert's Group utvecklas, så handlar det väl mer om att du ska komma in i olika varumärken, ta dem till större grejer.
Hur utvecklas du i att kunna driva bolag i framtiden som är 250 miljoner eller 500 miljoner?
Eller är din tanke att driva upp dem till 100, sälja av och börja om med små?
Vad är liksom nästa steg i varumärke i tanke i hur man jobbar?
Den ledarskapsgrejen eller den utvecklingen?
Nej, jag brukar inte spendera alltför mycket tid på problem jag inte har idag.
Att driva ett bolag som är 500 miljoner är klart en stor skillnad från att driva ett bolag som är 50 miljoner.
Jag har idag inget bolag som är 500 miljoner stort, så jag tar det problemet när det kommer brukar jag säga.
Dels det, och dels att historiskt då i och med att jag har gjort en del avknoppningar, har säljt av en del, så har vi aldrig kommit upp till 500 miljoner i omsättning.
Klart att det skulle vara kul.
Jag är ju den i hårt gäng som pushar för att behålla och inte sälja.
Jag har alltid gjort i alla case, i alla varumärken.
Dels så behöver inte jag mer kapital.
Jag känner någonstans att man kan vara fullgod och nöjd som människa.
Jag är där nu idag och har varit det ett tag så att jag behöver inte mer.
Jag har ingenting mer att åstadkomma av att göra ännu en dialeksigt.
Det hade varit så mycket roligare att nå den 500 miljoner eller en miljard eller skapa ett household brand som alla i Sverige känner till eller har på sitt bord.
Det är mitt yttersta mål någonstans.
Det hade varit kul att göra med något varumärke.
Problemet med det är att när man växer väldigt fort, som många av de bolagen som jag har investerat i har gjort, och gör vinst, så flockas man av erbjudanden runtomkring.
Det kommer vc-bolag, private equity-bolag, privata änglar, mäklare.
De knackar ju på dörren, inte till mig, utan till grundarna, i och med att de står som officiella ägare av bolaget och säger att det här bolaget är värt x och y, vilket det kan vara, absolut kan vara.
Då lockas man, eller frästas man eftersom det är oftast ens enda bolag.
Men att jag sitter på väldigt många stolar, har en diversifierad portfölj, så sitter man på sin enda stol och ser att, tänk om vi misslyckas.
Man sitter ju någonstans i en symbios ihop med mig och min byrå, och misslyckas byrån.
Man måste ju ha en enorm tilltro till att, okej, det här byrån kommer att lyckas driva bolaget till 500 miljoner, och bolaget kommer att vara värt mer då än vad det är idag.
Så där, och den är svår.
Så jag vet inte om jag någonsin kommer att få chansen att driva ett varumärke som är så stort, om inte jag själv startar det.
Och jag har testat att starta varumärken och jag har misslyckats varenda gång, och sagt till mig själv att nej, nu får det vara nog, jag ska inte starta fler varumärken.
Men ni har ett rödljusbolag, är inte det er egenstartat?
Absolut att det är dels egenstartat, i och med att jag var med från noll.
Men grundidén är från två kollegor som jag jobbade med.
Jag jobbade med två fina kollegor 2021, som hade ett bolag som hette Homey Life in Balance.
Fredrik och Sakina sålde det till Food.
Och någonstans ville jag köpa in mig i Homey Life in Balance innan det såldes.
Jag upptäckte det och sa redan efter första mötet att jag vill bli delägare.
De var lite tveksamma, jag förstod inte riktigt varför, men efteråt, efter bara några månader när de hade sålt det, så kom det fram att de var redan i processen att sälja bolaget.
Så det var jättekonstigt att jag hade köpt in mig i det bolaget.
Dels sålde de det när jag var jättelitet, vilket jag tyckte var, och de tyckte också var för tidigt, och lite konstigt.
Dels så hade de tusen andra idéer som de ville genomföra.
Cozy Life, det här rödljusbolaget, är ett av dem.
Så vi gick in som lika delägare, jag äger en minoritetsbost i det bolaget, men min byra är med och stöttar.
Kan du inte ta oss från, vi går tillbaks lite i tiden här, hur fick du loss pengar från start att kunna börja investera i bolag?
Vad kommer grundplåten ifrån?
Jag har haft en enkel uppväxt.
Jag växte upp i Norra Botkyrka, som är en av de mest utsatta områdena i Stockholm.
Och under hela mitt liv så hade man inte så mycket.
När vissa vänner hade fancykläder så gick man runt med ganska enkla grejer.
Och jag har aldrig behövt någonting och strävat efter att nu måste jag göra någonting mycket mycket större.
Så när jag väl sålde mitt första bolag som var det här taxibolaget, så satte man egentligen pengarna på spar.
Och man brukar säga att den som spar den har.
Dels har man ju kapitalinsats eller kontantinsats kanske till sin första lägenhet eller första bil.
Dels så jobbade man upp det.
Så jag var ganska framgångsrik e-handelskonsult, managementkonsult, man tjänar väldigt bra, tack och lov.
Annars hade jag inte haft någonting att investera.
Men sen tar man ju stora risker.
Så när jag startade på Robert Group hade jag precis haft en bra period bakom mig som ganska framgångsrik konsult i ett bolag som hette Improv, som sen såldes till Impact.
Där jobbade jag med brands som Sound Industries, Soap.se, Paradox, Rönish, Gymgro Sisten, din konkurrent.
Alla tror att vi heter det.
Ja, jag kan tycka det.
Du äger Gymgro Sisten, jag äger verkligen inte Gymgro Sisten.
Jag såldes för många år sedan.
Det är inte samma sak.
Nej, det är ett jättebolag det är.
Men sammanfattningsvis så är det lite av en grind bakom det här.
Du har sparat på dig snarare än en stor exit som ledde till att du kunde sätta igång nästa steg så att säga.
Ja, det var innan på Robertsgrupp och på Robertsgrupp då fick jag chansen att investera tidigt i brands.
Man kan säga att när jag var på min förra konsultbyrå så fick vi chansen att investera jätte, jätte tidigt i ett bolag som hette ZOO.se.
När ZOO var på sin tillväxtresa, sin e-handelstillväxtresa, de hade ju en butik som var framgångsrik och omsatt i 100 miljoner men om man bortser ifrån den enstaka butiken som är nästan som en Ica Maxi så var det en e-handelsresa som ledde till att de skulle fortsätta växa.
Och vi fick chansen att investera och köpa en stor del av det bolaget eller en stor minoritetspost.
Mina två delägare i det bolaget jobbade på att tackade nej.
Men jag fick blodad tand och tänkte att det här är ju jättedömt.
Varför vill man fokusera på sin core business inom situationsdäcken?
Och bara vara en konsultbyrå när vi har chansen att vara äkta delaktig partner i ett tillväxtcase som skulle kunna potentiellt vara värt 100-200 miljoner, trodde jag då.
Och det var det jag pitchade in.
Och spolar man fram några år så såldes ju faktiskt so.se, jag tror att det var 2021 eller i början av 2022, till e-equity, som deras dåvarande största investering på en värdering på typ 650 miljoner.
Så historien visade någonstans att jag hade rätt.
Och grundplattan jag la var ju väldigt, väldigt fin och väldigt, väldigt bra och jag hade i alla fall då väldigt bra kontakt med ägarna och det var väldigt tråkigt att vi inte gick in i det bolaget.
Men jag såg det mer som att det här är ett proof of concept.
Nu ska jag göra liknande grejer.
Och 2022 så gjorde jag ju min första stora dialexit i Under Your Skin där, som vart officiellt och som det skrevs om i tidningarna och efter det så har det ju bara rullat på.
När vi lyssnar på det här lite grann så är det lite, lite knepigt att hänga med.
Det är ganska många namn hit och dit och det är många olika företag och det är lite olika.
Finns det, om vi ska göra filmen om Fedja Porovic här om, nej vi ska inte fråga om du ska casta, det är alltid så här vanlig fråga i sådana här, det är inte den.
Men finns det några avgörande ögonblick under den här resan där du verkligen har fått de här insikterna om att fan, jag borde gå åt det hållet eller jag borde ha gjort, den här till exempel med ZO, mitt SC här, lät som faktiskt en insikt att varför är jag inte bara med och investerar i bolagen istället.
Men finns det några fler sådana ögonblick som du verkligen känner, det här, där tänkte jag till och det ändrade hela resan.
Men det finns några sådana i mitt liv.
Dels så var det när vi startade och sålde taxi Smart och såg att det här var ju inte e-handel, även om man på den tiden byggde det i en magent och lösning och kände att det här var e-handel.
Så var det ju inte e-handel med fysiska produkter, utan det var tjänster, tjänsterna hade låga marginaler.
Så där lärde man sig att behöva högre marginaler.
Och då var man med på en resa kring badrum på nätet och där lärde jag mig att shit, badrum på nätet är jättesvårt, det är ett enormt lagrigt rum för att man ska omsätta någonting.
Det kan hända så många fel på vägen.
Glas går sönder, kommoder går sönder, bara små repor och folk stör sig.
Så då ska jag till mig själv, jag ska aldrig jobba med sådana här stora paket, nu ska vi inte som IKEA platta paket om vi ska in i badrum.
Så det var två life changing moments.
Sedan träffade jag Sabrina Casale, som de sen friade till.
Det var ett sådant life changing moment för att hon fick mig att tänka helt annorlunda.
Och har dels varit med och bidragit att jag har fötterna på jorden.
Vi har två fina barn och har en helt annan livsvårdskådning.
På den tiden så var det mer race, race, race, jag ville snabbt göra saker.
Nu ser jag entreprenörskap mer som ett maraton.
Att vi kommer att leva säkert 80, 90, 100 plus år.
Låt oss tänka på entreprenörskap som en rolig grej som vi ska göra hela livet.
Och det är så tänkte man ju inte alls innan jag träffade min bättre hälft.
Och sen det som vi nämnde där kring zoo.se fick ju mig att inse att jag kanske skulle investera i varumärken istället för att bygga konsultbyrå.
Men konsultbyrån är ett nötvändigt ont.
Jag behöver backenden för att klara av att driva varumärken.
Speciellt om vi vill ha flera varumärken och satsa pengar på egentligen flera hästar samtidigt.
Det är det svåra.
Och sen en sista grej som hände var att när jag var ytyd som konsult och tjänade hur mycket pengar som helst, flera tusen lappar i timmen, så vart jag än kom ut till så var man i princip aldrig nöjd med den birhön jag representerade.
Utan det var alltid knäll, det var alltid tjat, det var alltid sida, alltid så.
Nej men det gillar vi fett, ja men vi får fakturer på flera hundratusen.
Och jag tänkte någonstans men det är ju bättre om jag skulle kunna på något sätt kunna fakturera efter värde.
Värdet man skapar är mycket mer tydligt.
Och värdet jag skapar skulle kunna vara oändligt jämfört med de tusenlappade timmen du kan tjäna som konsult.
Så där och då föddes den idén att jag behöver förändra i grund och botten hur en konsultbyrå fungerar.
Ja det är spännande.
Det är lite olika.
Olika delar i livet som har skapat de livslektionerna.
Jag tror att det låter som sunda delar.
När du har din råbetsgrupp här, utan att överdriva kan man ju säga att alla e-handlare hatar alla marknadsföringsbyråer.
För, säga att vi får fem samtal om dagen från folk som vill ta hand om våran Google marknadsföring.
Jag vet inte vad man kallar det här, säger man marknadsföringsbyrå?
Säg marknadsföringsbyrå.
Folk fattar vad jag menar, person med spiro är bra.
Men vi säger till exempel att jag är pappaledig, så att ingen ska kunna prata med mig, så jag får ju fyra medlemmar när någon dam får in.
Det är ju hörd att vara pappaledighet.
Jag har ju varit det i fyra år nu.
Men nu är det avslöjat.
Men när ni skulle börja bygga på Robots Group i början, hur gjorde du för att bygga varumärket så att ni faktiskt skulle utstråla någon sorts tillit?
För det måste vara tillit som är det isärklass viktigaste i den branschen.
Jo men det är det, tillit, absolut att tillit är, jag tror att tillit är jätte jätteviktigt.
Och dels så hade jag ju byggt någonstans ett personligt varumärke under de tio åren innan, och jobbat med de varumärkena som jag precis nämnde.
Fanns det även mainstream, det varumärket då, alltså ditt eget namn, kände vanliga e-handlare till det?
Jag tror det, det är jag med att när jag väl såg upp portarna så fick jag ett sånt poff enormt tillförsel till Byron.
Så att jag hade dels varit ut och förläst mycket, tillsammans med Google, tillsammans med Facebook, tillsammans med olika e-handelskeynotes.
Dels så hade jag varit med och gästat olika poddar.
Jag tror att innan jag stod ut på portarna så var jag redan med i E-commerce success.
Jag tror att jag var med i en annan podd.
Jag var med på e-handel.se ett par gånger.
Jag vet att någon av artiklarna till och med togs bort en av de tidigare artiklarna.
Oklart varför.
Så att jag var ju redan någonstans i branschen och hade figurerat lite överallt.
Men framförallt hade jag ett eget nätverk som litade på mig.
Problemen med mitt eget nätverk var att jag kom ju från en konsultbyrå och jag öppnade en konsultbyrå.
I och med att jag hade en ledande position och delägarskap i den konsultbyrån jag lämnar, så finns det vissa förhållningsregler som du behöver förhålla dig till.
Och jag kunde inte kontakta någon av dem som fanns i mitt nätverk.
Jag började om från noll, alltså jag hade inte min gamla e-postadress, jag hade inte mitt gamla telefonnummer, jag var tvungen att byta telefonnummer.
Du har ju världens bästa telefonnummer.
Nu har jag det.
Ja, det är fucking episkt.
Jag ska inte säga vad det är för då kommer folk att ringa.
Men det är så smidigt, telefonnummer till och med de första fyra siffrorna är logiska med fortsättningsnumret sen.
Tack.
Det måste du ha fjeskat med någon på Telia för att få.
Jag jobbade på Convict ett tag.
Jag var ansvarig för Convicts e-handel.
Så du smodde det bästa numret de hade.
Exakt.
Så att vi som jobbade där fick tillgång och fick se alla lediga telefonnummer hela tiden.
Så alla bra nummer lades alltid åt sidan.
Och man hade typ en månad på sig att paxa dem.
Så jag paxade ett par nummer där.
Det är som folk köper domäner när man säljer ut det sen.
Ja det gjorde jag aldrig.
Jag sparade dem till mig och till min egen.
Jag hade ett jätte jätte bra nummer även innan mitt nuvarande nummer.
Det fick jag tyvärr ge upp.
Jag fick inte tillbaka det.
Det har varit lite strul kring mitt telefonnummer någon gång långt sen när jag hade bytt och etablerat mitt nya nummer.
Då kontaktade de mig och sa att jag kan få över ditt gamla telefonen, men det gjorde jag inte.
Så någonstans, om man tänker tillbaka till frågan, ja när jag startade fick jag en anströmning av kunder så jag har aldrig behövt ringa ett kallt samtal, skicka ett mail, skicka en LinkedIn för frågan, i princip någonsin.
Och det är bara skönare sätt för att det är bättre att sitta på den sidan av stolen och få varumärken som hör av sig, kunna utvärdera och se om man är en bra fit eller inte, tacka nej till en stor del.
Men i början när man slår upp ortan, då tackar man ja till väldigt mycket.
Väldigt väldigt mycket.
Hade man gjort om resan hade jag nog varit mer restriktiv och inte vuxit så snabbt.
Vi gick från 0 till 10 anställda på typ 6 månader och det var ohälsosamt snabbt.
Det visade sig också i resultaten redan då.
Jag hade gjort om det, definitivt vuxit saktare idag.
Och gjort det mer stabilt och byggt alla processer och så vidare.
Hur många är ni idag?
Vi var nära 40, för drygt ett år sedan.
Men i och med att folk hoppar av, byter jag vi.
Eftersom man bygger upp ett så starkt namn, är med och syns och hörs överallt, så rycker folk i ens anställda till höger och vänster.
Man tänker att det här är ju guldkorn, de har lärt sig allt de kan, de kommer att få hur mycket insikter som helst.
Så att globalt sett så rycker ju folk i oss.
Och vi har varit runt 10-12 i Sverige kontinuerligt över de här åren.
3,5 åren, snart 4 som vi har funnits.
Och vi har varit runt 25-30 internationellt.
Och när folk får bra jobberbjudanden så har vi inte rekryterat nya, utan AI har utvecklats så pass mycket att vi klarar av att leverera samma tjänst eller en likartad tjänst med mindre personal.
Vilket var enligt plan.
Det var ingen, det var någonstans vi satte den här planen i början av 2023.
Vi har exekverat på planen fram till idag och kommer fortsätta att exekvera på den planen.
Jag tror att man kan göra väldigt mycket med färre personer idag jämfört med vad det var för bara två år sedan.
Ett exempel är sånt att all medier köpa automatiserats.
Det var det inte för två tre år sedan.
Finns det överhuvudtaget en framtid inom paid marketing för byråer eller kommer man i framtiden bara plug and play på Meta och...
Men om vi kollar, det beror på hur långt in i framtiden vi tittar.
Det är klart, tittar vi många år framåt så är det ju en väldigt dålig framtid för nuvarande reklambyråer eller marknadsföringsbyråer som finns.
Men väldigt stora bolag kommer fortsatt behöva hjälp av personer.
De kommer inte lita på att AI hanterar och hur ska de hantera de missarna som sker och när det sker en bug någonstans så ska den fixas och så vidare.
Men det kommer ju hanteras av färre individer.
Även på reklambyråerna.
Är det det som kommer bli den stora rollen för performancebyråer, att de snarare kommer granska och se så att inget ballar ur snarare än att hantera rätt?
Är det så du ser det?
Man kan jämställa det med logistik och den logistiska verksamheten som har hänt.
Det har ju kommit robotar som både hämtar varor, packar varor, kanske inte skickar varor, men du behöver någonstans en individ som granskar alla de här robotarna, sitter i system, övervakar på plats.
Och även i Amazons varuhus som är hela automatiserade så har du ju många anställda.
Så kommer du ju fortsatt vara även i byråsidan.
Jag ser inte än i en framtid de närmaste 5, 6, 10 åren där du helt kan klara dig utan en reklambyrö, utan någon typ av performance-byrå.
Men de byråerna som är kommer behöva gå mer mot strategihållet än vad de tidigare har varit.
Bli mer heltäckande som konsulter och inte vara så nischade såsom man har kunnat överleva på att vara en Google Ads-byrå.
Och bara nische in sig och bara enbart jobba med Google Ads.
I tio år har man kunnat göra fantastiska vinster.
Men det går typ inte idag.
Det är klart att det finns undantag.
Du kan inte starta en Google Ads-byrå 2024 och antag att du kommer göra vinster som precis digitala Adrealevens eller någon av de fina byråerna har gjort.
Nej det är rimligt.
Jag skulle säga det finns ju många sådana där olika branscher som alla hoppade in i.
I våran e-handelsvärde det är ju folk som började sälja klockor till exempel.
Det var ju alla började med det.
Och sen var det mobilskal och det var, eller omvänt kanske.
Det finns trender.
Ja exakt.
Och sen kanske man ska ge sig ut ur det.
När du utvärderar ett bolag för du säger att du sitter på andra sidan, utan det kanske är mer kunden som kommer till dig.
Vad är det du letar efter för att se att ni ska vara en bra match i detta?
Framförallt så är det att det är en bra grund, det är bra produkt som hjälper människan och mänskligheten på ett sätt, planeten på ett annat sätt.
Jag vill att det ska vara någon typ av värdedriven produkt i grund och botten.
På vilket sätt, nu retas jag bara, på vilket sätt hjälper smycken, mänskligheten?
Det är en bra fråga.
I början så kanske, så här, det här är de senaste tolv månaderna.
Vi har omvärderat vilka bolag vi arbetar med idag.
De bolagen vi har investerat i, till exempel smycken, smycken och klockor, jobbar vi mot att det här ska vara livstidsgaranti.
Vi är den första i branschen, vad jag vet så är vi kanske de enda i branschen som erbjuder vattentäta smycken med livstidsgaranti.
Och det betyder att du kan handla ett smycke en gång har du resten av livet.
Så har ingen annan i steinhällsstil, butyteri-sfären etablerat sig.
Så det vi gör är någonting som ska hålla.
Och även om vi skulle investera i kläder till exempel, ja det kanske inte hjälper mänskligheten i ytterligare ett klädvarumärke, men då vill jag att det ska vara ett syftesdrivet klädvarumärke.
Man kanske har hittat ett material som är mycket mer långvarigt så att du kan handla en t-shirt en gång och ha på dig den resten av livet.
Kanske överdrivet men du förstår vad jag menar.
Ja, jag tänker att du ändå är rätt, du upplevs ju som en rätt långsiktig människa som har tänkt igenom dina åsikter.
Är du intresserad, du säger att ni har omvärderat den genren, är det för att du ser att det är på det hållet som världen kommer hamna om 20 år, att vi alla behöver gå in i alla de här Green Blablabla initiatives från EU och sånt där, eller är det för att du har blivit farsan och du är ett mogen och nu vill du att världen ska bli lite bättre än vad den var när du var 18, eller är det en blandning eller hur, varför?
Det är en blandning men om man tittar på, om man går tillbaka till en sån här psykologisk marschloss på Ehotspyramid, i grund och botten när jag var lilla förortskillen, utstött, hade ingenting.
Jag gillar det svaret tror jag vet.
För jag bara, jag fattar, jag vart på väg, jag bara tycker det är ett ärligt och bra svar.
Jag tror att det är många som gör så, men de inte fattar det själva.
Men man behöver någonstans sätta mat på bordet, tak över huvudet, det är de här basgrejerna.
Du behöver värme, mat och tak.
När du har det så strävar du efter någonting mer.
Och när du har uppnått det så strävar du ofta efter någonting annat.
Och då kanske det är att du vill ha en bil eller någonting annat.
När du har tillräckligt mycket för att du kan se att okej, jag kommer att ha tillräckligt mycket för resten av mitt liv.
Och mina barn kommer inte gå hungriga.
Då har du andra oroer.
Och då tänker du okej, vad lämnar jag faktiskt efter mig?
Vad har jag byggt upp det här på?
Hur kan jag förändra och göra världen lite lite bättre än vad man skulle kunna ha gjort?
Så att det är väl åt det hållet som det har tagit mig.
Men det är klart att när du får barn så förändras ens perspektiv på livet.
Och man tänker ju hela tiden, om man läser ju, sen är det inte jag att du ska inte köpa en plastpåse, alltså ingen signalpolitik.
Det hatar jag, utan jag tänker mer långsiktigt och vad gör de stora effekterna?
Finns det varumärken som arbetar till exempel med återbruk, så är det ett bättre sätt att återbruka råvaror som redan är producerat, än att producera nytt.
Kan vi hitta på ett sätt att textilindustrin, som för övrigt är en av de värsta industrierna, kan bli lite bättre, så hade jag investerat i det och försökte kommersialisera det.
För någonstans så brukar de här green initiativbolagen vara dåliga på att kommersialisera produkterna.
Att man är bra i tanke, men man är dålig handlig.
Jag försöker föra samma de två.
Jag tycker att det är ett jättebra svar.
Jag blir alltid lika irriterad när poddgäster sitter, och så är det duktiga entreprenörer och så säger de vad drivs du av?
Nej men jag drivs inte av pengar, absolut.
Men du drevs av pengar.
För typ 99% av alla som startar bolag behövde någon gång pengar.
Det var ju det som var hela grejen då.
De får du att låta som att man ska bara drivas av passion.
Vilket är jättefint för de som kan det.
Men 99% kan inte det.
De måste fucking betala räkningar.
Det är så det funkar.
Men jag bara gillar det här med Maslows behov.
Och jag tycker också att det är en fin grej att varför kanske så många människor ger tillbaka sen när de blir rika eller framgångsrika.
Det är inte för att de var Ässholst, de var bara en annan verklighet.
Ja, jag tror att det är så att när man väl reflekterar över det så hamnar man där och man laddar där.
Och sen, som du nämner där, att jag drevs absolut av pengar för man vill alltid ha det man inte har här i livet.
När du bor i stan så vill du bo på landet, det är därför så många som skaffar sig ett landställe.
När du bor på landet så vill du flytta till stan.
En typisk sån kontradiktion.
Oavsett hur, när man är liten i alla fall och sen växer man ju upp någon gång och förstår hur det lägger till och att då vill man ju verkligen bo på landet.
Då vill alla bo på landet.
Lugn och ro, skönt.
Jag flyttade ut för tre år sedan när barnen kom.
Du bor i norra delen av jordklotet, du vill flyga till södra, du vill semestra på södra.
Du bor på södra delen av jordklotet och pratar med vem som helst i Afrika eller Italien, södra Italien eller södra Spanien.
Så vill folk som har uppvuxit upp, det här att flytta till norra delen för de tänker att det är mycket skönare med svalt temperatur.
Så man vill alltid ha någonstans det man inte har.
Gräset är alltid grönare på andra sidan.
Absolut.
Vi började den här diskussionen av att jag frågade vad du letar efter när du ska investera i ett bolag.
Okej, du letar efter en hållbar idé.
Vad finns det med dig?
Det måste vara bra entreprenörer i grunden som vi klickar med, som är på samma plan halva som jag är på.
Jag investerar fortfarande att det ska vara ett vinstdrivet bolag.
Är det samma plan halva personlighetsmässigt, att ni har kul ihop och tänker samma, eller är det att ni tänker på business på samma sätt?
Jag tror att det är med att vi tänker på business på samma sätt.
Vi behöver absolut inte ha kul ihop, jag tror inte jag har investerat.
Jag har inte umgått med någon av de bolagen på en privat plan.
Nu kanske det blir en förändring i det också, gör med att jag har hittat ett brand som jag och grundaren verkligen trivs.
Det är farligt.
Det är lite farligt.
Man lockas ju ta av att spendera tid på olika onödiga grejer då.
Men samma businessplan halva, vi måste ha ett vinstdrivande tänk.
Trots att det är ett gott syfte så måste det vara kommersiellt gångbart.
Det ska helst vara skalbart, det ska vara bra marginal.
Nu ser jag ju ganska många olika saker här som vi tittar på.
Det är, helst ska det vara en naturligt återkommande kund.
Behöver inte vara det men helst.
Få nera typ att du säljer proteinpulver i bolaget och då har du en naturligt återkommande kund där proteinpulveret tar slut.
Då vill du att folk ska komma tillbaka igen.
Smycken var ju inte så.
Du har ingen naturligt återkommande kund.
Utan du behöver alltid uppfinna hjulet på nytt.
Vilket gör att det är väldigt rent känsligt.
Det är utom min, inte expertis men att jag måste förlita mig på att andras människors arbete ska generera tillväxt.
Jag gillar att vara chef av mitt eget öde.
Så naturligt återkommande kund, tänk hudvårdsprodukter, kosmetikaprodukter, proteinpulver, mat, den typen av städprodukterna som vi har i Västerbottens sopa och så vidare.
Så en del olika parametrar men framförallt är det att det ska vara en bra produkt och entreprenörerna bakom ska vara normala.
Det är subjektivt, var är normalt för mig kanske inte normalt för dig.
Absolut inte.
Ni har ett motto på er grupp som heter We think big and move fast, we build stuff that breaks.
Det låter som ett motto som ni förstår men inte jag förstår.
Vad betyder det?
Den är lite svår, någonstans så kan man, och det här grundade sig i när vi startade Byron på Råbytsgrupp, att vi kan bygga saker långsamt, stadigt, stabilt.
I alla fall på den tiden när all den erfarenheten jag kom ifrån grundade sig att du kommer på en idé, du finslipar den idén, du bygger den idén och du planerar hur du ska marknadsföra din idén, du anlitar peer-biroer och konsultbiroer och så gör man.
Och så tänker man att helt plötsligt kommer kunderna att komma.
Det gör de ju sällan.
Utan det finns ingen perfekt produkt från start.
Då är det bättre att bygga någonting, lansera det, få direkt feedback från riktiga konsumenter och sen bli bättre över tid.
Det vill säga optimera, editera, gå tillbaka till ritbrädan, göra om, göra rätt.
Och då har man spillerat absolut att du har spillerat tid även i den processen.
Du har kommit mycket närmare konsumenterna.
Och det här grundar sig ifrån egentligen en filosofi som man framför allt har inom SaaS-världen.
Service as a subscription.
Jag vet inte helt vad det är.
Product as a service?
Nej vänta.
Sales as a service.
Jag vet ju vad du menar.
Service as a subscription.
Okej SaaS.
Det borde vi inte kunna.
Netflix, Spotify är typiskt två stora bolag som är SaaS-bolag.
Det grundas ju i att du ska inte sitta och fila på en funktion som du inte har testat först.
Ut med det att testa det, få feedback från användarna och sen bygg klart det.
För du kan bygga fantastisk kod i din databas men den fantastiska koden kanske tar tre år att bygga klart.
Det är mycket bättre att spotta ut någonting på tre veckor och sen fila på det om det verkligen fungerar.
Dra tillbaks den funktionen, fila på det de här tre åren men då vet du från data att det fungerar.
Så bygg saker som går sönder de här tre veckorna, de testade redan, de älskade den funktionen, den gick sönder, bygg klart det, lansera det.
Ja exakt, jag köper det.
Vi har ju själv gjort ett flertal sådana fel.
Man kanske tagit in en ny kategori av produkter och sen har man tänkt att det här ska bli stort och sen inser man att ingen köper det.
Man hade ju egentligen bara kunnat starta en kategori, lagt in lite saker på dropship och sett om det överhuvudtaget funkar.
Man kanske förlorar pengar på de produkterna just då, men man ser om det är en valid kategori.
Ja, det är jättebra strategi.
Vi applicerar det i att vi säljer saker som inte finns.
Vi kan sälja saker på skiss och så ringer vi upp de kunderna och säger att hej tyvärr, den här produkten har vi inte tillverkat klart än, vi vet inte hur den handlar på sajten.
Man blir dem ursäkt, de får en annan produkt så att slutkonsumenten blir alltid kompenserad.
Men då har man ett valid test i att folk vill verkligen köpa saker.
Ett jättebra exempel på det är när du frågar dina Instagramföljare.
Du kan fråga dina Instagramföljare vad de vill ha och de kommer rösta och du kommer tro att shit, det är kul att jag har tänkt på exakt samma grej.
Jag vet inte men jag testade nyligen i ett av varumärkena som jag har som heter Success som säljer Ridsport.
När vi bygger en hel kollektion tillsammans med användarna.
Och sen lanserar man den kollektionen och exakt de personerna som var med och röstade hela vägen är absolut inte de som handlar.
Så att folk en gång i tiden sa väl Henry Ford någonstans att om jag hade frågat folk vad de egentligen ville ha så hade de sagt snabbare hästar.
De visste inte, folk vet inte vad de vill ha innan de blir presenterade i alternativet.
Jag tänker att ett till sånt är ju när man frågar alltid vad skulle du kunna tänka dig att betala för detta och så säger folk alltid, ja men 250 spänn och det stämmer ju aldrig någonsin.
Ingen av de servicen stämmer någonstans någonsin.
Utan man måste testa, folk ska kunna sätta sina hårt tjänade pengar bakom en produkt, då vet man att det fungerar.
Jag ska ta en sista fråga här.
När ni går in i ett nytt varumärke eller olika varumärken, finns det någonting rent övergripande som ni typ alltid ser att de gör fel?
Finns det några så här lågt hängande frukter som folk kan ta till sig och bara förbättra det, bli bättre på det, det ger så mycket value?
Jag skulle säga storytelling.
Det är övergripande fel bland amerikanska entreprenörer, mycket bättre på det här.
Om man sneglar över på amerikanska startups, framförallt startups, så ser man att de grundas, man har en klar vision och man är duktig på att förmedla den visionen utåt.
Jag tycker inte att svenska entreprenörer ens är i närheten.
Och det har jag byggt många av våra bolag på.
Varför gör du det du gör bättre än alla andra?
Få ut det i budskapet klart och tydligt överallt och var konsekvent.
Det är svenska entreprenörer väldigt dåliga på.
Så det är det första som en av de få första och enhetligt liknande grejer.
De måste bara ge dig cred för den.
För igår sa jag till min flickvän här då att jag ska till Stockholm imorgon och då ska jag snacka med Fedja Porovic.
Det vet inte jag vän det är.
Hon jobbar som lärare så hon skiter i den här världen.
Men jag var okej, han har investerat i under your skin.
Då sa hon är det inte det där varumärket?
Hon hade lite dålig hy eller någonting.
Så hon köper inte ens produkterna men hon vet om storyn bakom.
Bara det säger att man har faktiskt lyckats med storyn eftersom det är det enda hon känner till om det varumärket.
Det är lite häftigt faktiskt.
Det är väldigt häftigt.
Vi bankar in och är konsekventa över tid.
Oftast så grunder ju folk bolag med en tydlig vision och man vet vad man vill.
Det handlar inte bara om att tjäna pengar.
Ja alla vill tjäna pengar, många vill tjäna pengar.
Men varför och på vilka grunder har du startat bolaget?
Varför gör du det?
Alltid när man säger storytel, jag tycker det som är knepigt med det, är det inte att 90% av alla människor har väl ingen riktig storytel?
Om du öppnade ett ICA där du bor liksom, det är att jag vill ta mat till människorna, det var ju inte därför du öppnade ICA.
Eller du öppnade ett varumärke inom telefonskal, säger vi, för det har många gjort.
Det var inte så att de ville förändra världen, de ville ju inte det.
Vad gör man om man inte har en story?
Men oftast, om vi tar någon av dem, så har de ju troligtvis ett varför.
Den som öppnar en ICA där det inte finns en ICA, eller det finns ingen matbutik idag, i grund och botten så kanske den öppnade den butiken för att den ville ha ett kurerat utbud till de som är stammisar, eller som bor i närheten, så att man tänker att de här stora butikerna som Coop, eller säger att det var Citygross i närheten, inte har någon koll på vad folk verkligen handlar.
Och så har ju många lyckats speciellt i till exempel Stockholmsförokt, där jag är ifrån.
Där har du ju poppat upp butiker som tar in varor från andra delar av jorden, där populationen är ifrån.
Och man tänker sig att varför skulle det finnas en hel hylla med Balkanmat, eller en hel hylla.
Det är ju så att kulturen har spridits, det är därför vi äter tacos på fredag, eller har pizza.
Ja, vi stod för, jag bodde i Majerna förut, jag tror vi stod för halva konsumtionen av Iran, min flicka när jag syr.
När hon var gravid så drack hon bara.
Iran, ja men Iran är ju gott, det är ju ett bra exempel.
Och där har ju någon öppnat butiken i tron av att okej jag vill förändra, och jag vill hämta produkter som jag tror att människor vill ha.
Jag, någonstans så finns det en story bakom det, och Billskalen fanns troligtvis en story bakom det också.
Man kanske inte bara tänkte att okej, Idol of Sweden har gjort det här, de växer fort, de syns överallt, de gör det här lönsamt.
Utan man kanske tänker att, jag vill inte associeras med vad de hade då, en sån här marble mobilskal.
Går jag ut så finns det bara svarta, gråa, tråkiga mobilskal.
Jag vill göra någonting stilrent eller jag vill göra någonting i vegans läd, eller jag vill göra någonting som är customized.
Om du inte har en story, ska du hitta på en story då?
Oftast så finns det någonting, och som gräver man och ställer rätt frågor så har varje entreprenör ett varför.
Jag tror inte man behöver hitta på en story.
Om man tänker på den storyn som din fru nämner så var det en för dom entreprenörerna så var det en självklarhet.
Men för alla utomstående inklusive mig så var det en ögonväckare.
Det här måste man ju kunna dela med sig av för troligtvis om det har hänt dig, så har det hänt fler.
Personen som startade det mobilskalsvarumärket eller den ICA-butiken var säkert ute efter någonting som inte fanns på marknaden just där och då, eller kunde göra det bättre eller billigare.
Kan man göra det billigare så får du ju människor att spara pengar och då finns det en story i det.
Du har ju en bra story skulle jag säga i gymkompaniet också, även om du i grund och botten kanske tänkte att det här ska vi starta för att jag själv vill ha bra produkter, välkurrera till ett schysst pris, så växer ju story någonstans fram tillsammans med kunderna.
Jag kan faktiskt säga, jag brukar aldrig säga, men vår story är att jag vill ha ett företag så som jag tycker att företag ska funka.
Det är det jag vill ha bara.
Det ska vara chill, kan inte folk bara få komma och gå lite som de vill, kan vi inte bara låta alla ha sitt ansvar, jag ska inte lägga mig i och folk ska bara få, kan vi inte bara vara avslappnade.
Ibland gör man roligt, ibland blir det tråkigt, ibland jobbar man mer, ibland har man lunch vid den tiden.
Vi ska ta in saker och göra det enkelt.
Inget, det är hela min...
Företagsfilosofi.
Ja, så går alla beslut.
Det är ändå en vacker företagsfilosofi, jag kan associera och tänka väldigt mycket i de barnen också.
Det är mycket så att vi bygger på Robert Group.
Mycket eget ansvar, mycket flexibilitet, folk får äta, gå, komma, sluta, vabba, bobba, vad du vet, när det behövs.
Så vi anpassar egentligen, vi brukar säga att det finns bara, det finns inte ett arbetsliv och sen ett privat liv, utan de går hand i hand väldigt mycket idag.
Det finns ett livpunkt, du behöver få det att gå ihop.
Och då måste du kunna anpassa arbetet så gott det går efter livet.
Exakt.
Inte anpassa hela livet efter arbetet, vilket tråkigt liv du kommer ha.
Ja, exakt.
Vi hade någon som, eller alla typ, har hund.
Då satte vi upp ett hundrum på lagret, så folk kan ha sin hund där, så de kan gå ut på.
Ja, vad snyggt.
Eller sådana här.
Det är fint.
Eller den här podden.
Vi får inga extra kunder av detta, men det är en kul grej och jag tycker det är kul.
Fuck it, vi testar detta.
Gör det långsiktigt så får ni kunder av det också, jag lovar.
Ja.
Vi ska inte fastna i det.
Storytelling, viktig grej.
Finns det något mer som grej?
Nej men det finns jättemånga sådana grejer.
Dels är ju folk väldigt dåliga, tycker jag, på content.
Oftast så visar man inte tillräckligt mycket varför folk ska handla av dig.
Om vi kollar konsumentprodukter i snitt så är det väldigt otydligt varför behöver jag handla den här produkten av dig.
Så varför ska jag handla av gymkompaniiet?
Det framgår inte tillräckligt tydligt på alla sidor jag landar på.
Och absolut inte i annonserna heller.
Det är en sån sak som jag direkt börjar tänka okej, vad är nyttan, värdet för slutkonsument?
Det måste framgå överallt.
Frifrakt är inte en sån ösp.
Alla har någonstans frifrakt över en viss gräns, speciellt om det finns en gräns.
Klart att det ska vara tydligt, jag säger inte att det inte ska vara det.
Men det är ju inte en konkurrensfördel.
Det är inte en konkurrensfördel att ha gratis retur eller att det ska vara bra kundtjänst eller bra service.
Det är någonstans vad man förväntar sig som konsument.
Så förväntningsnivån har också snäppet rört sig över åren till det som Amazon har i USA, eller det som Zalando etc.
har levererat bra i Sverige.
Så att vi konsumenter blir mer och mer kräsna desto längre tiden går, desto fler år det är, och förväntar sig mer av bolaget.
Och då måste man titta på vad det finns för andra bakomliggande värden som vi är mycket, mycket bättre på.
Vi måste framhäva de sakerna överallt.
Så att det är väldigt, väldigt tydligt.
Så content tycker jag att väldigt många bolag slarvar med.
Och jag brukar säga att allt är content.
Er lagepersonal är content.
Tittar vi på hur vi jobbar med Västerbottens sopa, vi är jättetransparenta.
Vi går och filmar i lagret, alla får vara delaktiga, dels får det alla på samma sida.
Bolaget känns enat, alla är glada.
Det är en jättekonstig stämning när jag kommer in i fabriken eller i lagret.
Folk är stolta över att arbeta på Västerbottens sopa.
Den stoltheten vet man också att det kommer de bära med sig hem, det kommer de prata med människor om och alla som jobbar på bolaget är bolagets ambassadörer.
De kommer synas i vår egen media, sociala medier och vara ännu mer stolt efter det.
Så egentligen allt är content, alla är content.
Från det här avsnittet skulle man kunna skapa upp hundra olika små klipp, små citat, man kan göra en blogg utav det, man kan la publiceringen på olika typer av medier.
Så för varje liten dag som går så finns det massor av content som händer runt omkring som man kan dela.
Det som har blivit en stor, enorm trend som jag tycker att folk helt missar, typ som gymkompagniet skulle kunna göra, är det bara live streama det som händer bakom kulisserna.
Till exempel att någon i lagret plockar och packar ordrar och samtidigt svarar på kunder.
Tänk nu bara att sätta på kameran, noll redigering, noll fix, noll förberedelse.
Bara sätta på en kamera, gå live, visa att den här orden packar vi till Lycksele idag.
Det är två hantlar som går iväg.
De här hantlarna är bra för att tjick, tjick, tjick.
Aha, och alla som sitter där och tittar blir både lite såhär okej, vad är de hantlarna bra för, men framförallt för att driva tiden.
Folk har ju tröttnat lite på docusåper, folk har tröttnat på mycket och annat.
Det är livesändningar som går väldigt väldigt bra.
Många bolag har byggts stora på livesändningar.
Folk gillar, vår största återkommande följtång är, vi är ut och bygger gym, jag och en kollega oftast då.
Då bär vi ju i trappor och då brukar vi filma trappan.
Det är liksom världens tråkigaste content, men folk efterfrågar alltid den där trappan för att se hur jävla jobbigt, det är skitjobbigt att vara löpande upp och ner för trappor.
Då tycker de att det är kul att se att vi har gjort det.
Hur man ju lyckas med det.
Vi filmar inte ens när vi bär, vi bara filmar att den trappan finns.
Och så är det såhär, vi har fallit tio personer som skriver i DMs typ, haaaaaa, du vet.
Det är det sämsta innehållet som finns, men folk gillar det.
Men det blir lite er grej.
Ja, och som sagt, allt kan vara content.
Ni är den där trappan content.
Ja, jag ska inte ta mer av din tid, för det här var fantastiskt spännande.
Det är väldigt roligt att få grotta ner sig lite i dina tankar.
Jättestarkt samt.
Tack för att du bjöd mig in i podden Joel, och för att dela någonting, och hoppas att man har fått med sig någonting av avsnittet.
Det hoppas jag.
Tack tack.
Gött, gött.
Jag bodde i Majerna för att jag tror vi stod för halva konsumtionen av Iran.